this in-depth course is tailored for job
Seekers at all levels providing you with
the essential skills and insights to
succeed in behavior-based interviews
while many developers focus on preparing
for technical interviews you should also
prepare for the other parts of job
interviews parth is an experienced
instructor and provides a bunch of
Insider tips and Industry expertise so
whether you're targeting a role in a top
company or just starting your
professional Journey this course is your
key to navigating behavioral interviews
with ease Hello friends so now we are
going to have a full course on how you
can master your behavioral interviews so
first let's understand that what is
going to be the outline of the course
and what you can expect from this course
number one thing we are going to learn
is the introduction and the importance
of Behavioral interviews what they are
and why do they matter in the actual
interview system next we are going to
learn about the star method it is a way
for you to articulate your answers for
the behavioral interview questions so
that you can represent them in a better
format next we will learn about how you
can prepare research and present your
answers in a methodical tactical Manner
and I will we will talk about all the
different strategies that they are about
researching yourself the company you are
applying for the culture you need to
understand and we will go deep with
couple of case studies as well plus we
will learn about the different
categories of Behavioral interviews and
then we will reach to the meat of our
problem that is 50 different behavioral
interview questions and what is the
intent for those questions and what
should be the expected answers that the
interviewer is going to look forward so
this is going to be the most important
topic and next in the end we will talk
about how you can deal with difficult
questions what are some of the
non-verbal communication cues you have
to understand and in the very end we
will talk about some resources and
follow-ups that would be really useful
for your upcoming behavioral interview
preparation now first let me introduce
myself really quickly my name is par vas
and I have been in the IT industry for
10 plus years now uh on the side I run
my own YouTube channel called
destination Fang where I teach about
different technical system design and
behavioral interview topics questions
and concerns so if you want feel free to
go ahead and check it out it would be
really helpful um my hobbies include
watching lots of movies playing lots of
Call of Duty and going on lots of hikes
now lastly let me just talk about few
fun facts about myself so I have Masters
in computer science last year I became a
dad of two beautiful twin daughters and
originally I was born and raised in
India but since last 10 years I been
living in Canada now let's see that what
are the different types of interviews we
can expect to face in any sort of tech
interview process now number one is the
technical interview which can vary from
either data structure and algorithm
related problems or maybe some
technology agnostic or technology
specific kind of questions maybe like
Java python related problem or if you're
applying something for data scientist
maybe there can be some variations for
that technical interview process next is
a system design interview where you are
typically talking about the broad ocean
of computer science and distributed
system Concepts where you talk about
everything related to how you want how
you can build a more resilient and
desirable system if you have to build
your own Twitter or Google like system
how would you do that what are the
trade-offs you would consider and third
one is the behavioral interview that we
are going to put most of our emphasis on
for this portion of the rest of the
course now behavioral interviews are
very important for Tech roles on top of
it they are also generically apply to
all sorts of jobs because you can
imagine every single company wants to
hire an employee who is going to be a
good culture fit and the purpose of
behavioral interview is to identify that
what type of person you are and will you
be a good uh potential candidate to hire
or not so now let's see that what
behavioral interviews are behavioral
interviews are mostly tend to focus on
your past experience of what are the
things you have done what are the
situations you have faced what are the
experiences you have gained and based on
those experiences situations and answers
you give the companies or the
interviewers would predict that how
successful candidate you would be in the
future so rather than focusing on just
random questions they tend to put more
emphasis on what you have faced what you
have earned and what you did in those
scenarios on top of it what did you
learn from that the purpose of these
interviews are quite simple they wants
to assess or they wants to judge that
how good of a candidate you would be but
based on the real life examples and real
life experience you have faced in in
your previous uh career so throughout
this point so they are slightly
different from the traditional
interviews we used to have because
typically we all have faced some sort of
interviews where we are being asked
questions like where do you see yourself
in 5 years if you are in a situation
where you have a conflict with someone
how would you resolve that or if you
have to do this or if you have to do
that so
basically typically pre people used to
ask hypothetical questions and then at
some point they realize that rather than
focusing on hypothetical scenarios and
Imagination of candidate it would be
good to understand that what type of
situations they have faced and how did
they deal with them so based on those
real life examples and experiences they
would be able to judge that how good of
a candidate you are which means they
wants to assess your interpersonal
skills and problem solving abilities
based on your real life experiences and
real life examples uh so which is quite
a major turn from the hypothetical
scenar scenarios that previously used to
dominate the the job market uh more
focus is put on the examples and
specific tasks that you have you have
achieved throughout your career rather
than just random questions or the
typical questions that previously used
to be the majority of part of the
interview now the question is why does
behavioral interviews matter so much in
the actual hiring process and the reason
is actually quite simple the behavioral
interviews are designed in a manner that
they tend to predict your Performance
Based on the answers you give and based
on the experiences you have realized now
think from the company's perspective
hiring any single candidate is a very
expensive task and very resource
incentive task for the companies because
number one they will have to post the
jobs they will have to go through maybe
100 resumés then they would have to
interview at least 15 to 20 candidates
and the interviewers tend to be the
senior level Focus
which means the higher and senior level
folks are not doing their job but rather
they're spending their working hours
interviewing various different
candidates and what if they hire a
candidate and after 6 months they
realize that that candidate is maybe
lazy or that candidate does not listen
to their manager or does not follow
directions always have issues with all
of the co-workers who is not a good
person to work with all of these issues
and then company would realize that now
they might have to replace that person
so if replacing can also come with their
own consequences maybe they have to pay
them some severance package and once
again they would have to go through this
whole hiring process to find a better
suitable candidate which means companies
really wants to make sure that they vet
before they hire any single candidate
and that's why even if you lack in
technical skills it can still be learned
but if you lack in the correct attitude
and the right mindset for sure companies
is going to reject you immediately so
that is why it is it becomes really
imperative and important for any company
to make sure that before they hire
someone they critically judge their
skill set their attitude how they behave
with other people how should they behave
in different teams and that's why these
becomes really important because
behavioral interviews they help to find
the candidate with right attitude right
mindset who is going to thrive in their
jobs who is going to take the company
forward with the vision and with their
culture so that is why uh behavioral
interviews are really important on top
of it behavioral interviews are actually
a great tool for the interviewer as well
how because you can dictate the pace and
the answers you can explain and this is
an open ground for you so treat it as an
opportunity for you to convey your
interviewer that hey these are the
things I have been through these are the
situations I was in I was all of these
scenarios these are the things I learned
from that this is my attitude this is
how I behave this is how I deal with
tough situation so it's an open ground
for you to score as many goals as you
can uh and think of uh even the real
life scenarios why do great teams always
wants to hire someone who has been
performing really good for last two two
to three years because they know that
they can they have the quantifiable
measures or they have the the real
numbers to present that this player
maybe Cristiano Ronaldo or Messi why
they are good or why they are goats
because consistently they have shown
that they can perform well under
pressure situation they can deal with
different task different teams different
championships they have lost they have
been battered they have been injured and
still they jump back still they came
back so they have the right attitude and
that what makes them Elite athletes and
same thing applies for any single
company as well that they wants to to
hire a person with the correct mindset
that even if they make mistakes they
learn from that uh and that's why it's
really important for you to pay utmost
attention to the behavioral portion of
the interview as well you can be the
greatest technical mind in the in the
world but if you don't have the correct
mindset no company is going to hire you
because no one wants to work with
someone who is not a nice person so
always always put more emphasis on the
way you convey yourself the Way You Are
going to present yourself in an
interview because this is an open ground
for
you now let's talk about the way you are
going to approach the questions in an
actual behavioral interview and for that
we have a very popular me method called
star method it is nothing but a
mechanism for you to for formulate and
articulate your answers before you
present them to the interviewer for any
given question star is nothing but the
abbreviation for situation task action
and result
and what the interviewer wants you to do
is that they wants you to completely
give all the answers in this sequence so
this is a timeline that you have to
follow in order to provide your answer
so let's try to break down the star
method and we will try to understand it
with some examples as well so first what
you need to do is whenever any question
is being asked at you what you can do is
you can explain that what was the
situation what was the back story on why
you needed to do that thing uh in which
you are providing all the context you
are providing that what happened what
was the scenario what H what was
happening with the company what was uh
being asked for you to do uh what was
the overall scenario that would impact
your judgment or your decision next you
will have to Define that what was the
task that was expected of you that what
you needed to work on what you needed to
complete how you needed to do that uh
what were some of the additional
constraints and you provide all of that
information for the action you need to
provide the exact specific things that
you did and I'm providing more emphasis
on the word you because many times we
tend to feel that in a larger project we
always say that yeah we were trying to
build this and we were trying to do that
and then we ended up doing this and then
this our team completed this we try to
give credit to other people because it
would seem like we are a person who who
feel gratitude for the work of others
and appreciates that and of course you
should have that quality no issues with
that but in the interview the
interviewer is trying to judge what you
specifically did what you were
responsible for and what were the
actions that you took so you need to
provide those actions and last thing
would be that what was the result that
was achieved how did you do that and
what improvements that made based on the
actions you took so see the whole story
that you are explaining everything and
then you are saying that what you need
to do it's just like a movie it's a
timeline you are going in one sequence
from one point A to point B while
explaining everything that was asked in
the context of the of the question now
let's try to think of this with an
example maybe the interviewer asked you
a question that give me an example where
you had a disagreement with your product
manager or with your supervisor and how
did you deal with that situation
so you can give some example like this
first you would Define what was the
situation so situation could be that um
you already had a company that was that
had a very nice Tex stack on maybe
Microsoft Azure and you had lot of
services and applications already up and
running uh but for that time your
manager wanted to create uh the
microservice cluster from the existing
monolith application and it needed to be
done on an urgent and immediate basis so
for that uh if they had to deploy
everything in the cloud maybe there were
some bureaucracies or some process that
you might have to follow that would have
caused some additional time constraint
so that is why the manager's approach
was that because we needed to get this
done as quickly as possible can you move
everything on the on premises service
servers and once we deploying the
production maybe we can think about what
we need to do uh later because managing
the monolith application was becoming a
huge burden um so this was the this was
the situation now the task on your hand
was that you were responsible for
creating though or breaking down that
monolith application into the cluster of
microservices and uh you maybe the team
was short staffed and you were tked to
complete this by this time and date and
deadline but your approach was that
since the rest of the company is already
working on the cloud computing and you
are trying to become a cloud native
company where you are trying to get rid
of all the on premise server servers and
devices uh maybe you can mention that
the even though manager explicitly said
that hey this would speed up the pro the
production and spe ra we need to ramp
this up completely and pretty quickly uh
your suggestion was that based on the
experience it would make more sense to
deploy all of these things in the cloud
and create a cloud native app from the
scratch rather than building everything
um from the ground up and then deploying
in the company server and then once
again providing or adding additional
resources to move them to the cloud
eventually so this was this was the
situation and this was the task that you
needed to do and this was the
disagreement between yourself and your
manager next you can talk about that
what were the actions you took so as an
action I explained to my manager I
convinced them that uh hey these are the
different challenges we currently have
since we are already trying to get rid
of the on premise service servers they
would be decommissioned soon and uh even
if we build everything right now and we
we migrate everything though the de
development and deployment might be
faster but still we would have to
provide an additional resources and in
order to move all of these once again
back to the cloud so why not we just
spend all the effort in one time and
build a cloud native application that is
going to be more resilient and it would
be it would serve the company better in
the long run so this was the discussion
you had and then later as as sort of the
actions you did some calculation that
how much time and effort and resources
will it take for you to move to the on
premise and then once again move to the
cloud or if you have to build build
everything from scratch and directly
move to the cloud what would be the
differences what are going to be the
pros and cons of each approach what are
going to be the benefits and after
providing all of the resources and all
of the details you explained to the to
your manager and then manager came to to
an agreement that okay uh maybe it would
make more sense to deploy to the cloud
rather than relying on the on promise
servers that is all on already going to
be decommissioned so as an action you
had your monolith application broken
down into a very good cluster of
microservices that got deployed in the
cloud and now you have a more resilient
Cloud native service so this can be your
answer in the star method where you
break down every single component and
you explain the pros and cons of each
one of them you walk the VI through the
scenario and explain that what were the
exact specific actions you took how did
you dealt with the disagreement did you
just completely discarded the approach
from the manager or were you listening
on both sides of the coin did you
properly assess the situation did you
analyze how would you do that and after
you give this kind of answer it is going
to be much more impactful uh plus the
interviewer would be able to follow
along throughout your whole story and
whole journey so once you give this
answer the interviewer can have better
follow-up questions and they would know
you better that you are the person who
takes into the consideration of all the
all the things you think about the
long-term you think that what is going
to be the best for the company rather
than just getting the immediate thing
done for the sake of doing it so these
are the things that leave a lasting
impact on the interviewer's mind on top
of it it is always going to be really
good practice to always frame your
answers in this scenario that is why
star method is really important and
always whenever you are trying to answer
any question make sure that you you lay
out the situation first and then you
move or build on top of it follow the
timeline and this is going to be really
easy for interviewer to follow on top of
it you would be able to explain the
whole thing and you can also recall the
same scenario on your mind as well that
okay initially my manager reached out to
me and then we had this discussion and
then we had this discussion I did this
thing behind the scenes I learned about
this I created these charts or these
comparisons between both the available
approaches and then we made a
quantifiable and concrete decision that
it would be better to go with approach a
or approach B based on these scenarios
and this was the task you did and this
was the result you achieved so it really
looks nice and always make sure that
whenever you are trying to build your
answers you are framing them in the star
method for that you might need to do
some practicing behind and and we are
going to talk about all of this in the
later part of the video that how can you
prepare better uh but make sure that you
are aware about the star methodology
because more and more companies they
wants their answers to come in this
Frame okay so after understanding what
star method is now let's dive deep into
how do you actually start preparing for
different stories different answers and
different scenarios for that you will
actually have to do some back back work
and then we will move forward so let's
understand that the very first thing you
need to do in order to prepare for your
behavioral interviews that is to self
reflect you will have to identify that
what are the things you are good at what
are the things you not good at and how
can you improve yourself so for that you
always needs to go and make sure that
you are using the correct and different
methods to verify that what are the
personal strengths you carry some of the
methods you can think of is maybe uh
asking questions to other
self-reflecting on past experiences
getting feedback maybe from your manager
from your co-worker or from your ex
employers uh reaching out to different
people thinking or researching on the
current situation you are in and many
times this may sound odd but many times
Anonymous boards can be really really
helpful uh and why am I saying all of
these things like you can choose
whatever you want you can go ahead ahead
and start journaling if you want the
reason I'm saying about Anonymous boards
is because many times if you explain
your situation in places like Reddit or
blind or some place most of the people
yeah there will be some Trolls but most
people are going to be neutral and they
won't know you personally so they would
completely be non-biased towards you uh
so that can sometimes work in your favor
but it's a slippery slope so you need to
be very careful with Anonymous feedback
but apart from that there are lot of
different methods to uh self-reflect and
self identify that what should be what
are your strengths what are your
weaknesses and over the course of the
period you must have experienced and
learned something you have been in this
world for few years now so for sure you
must have some idea that hey these are
the things I'm good at these are the
things I'm not good at and this is how I
can frame my answer if I have to give
you an example about my strengths and my
weaknesses like uh I personally believe
believe that I tend to get really
involved in the conversation I like to
communicate with people I somehow I feel
that my communication skills are
slightly better so these would be my
strong points maybe my weak points I
tend to dive so deep into the
introduction and rather than just saying
my things exactly I try to create a huge
Preamble before I dive deeper into the
main issue so that can be one of my
weaknesses um uh many times I tend to
procrastinate so that was that is
another of my weakness how can I improve
upon them what are the steps I can take
maybe I can write down my goals maybe I
can uh do some things to make changes
and these are these self-reflection
tools would be a would make you a better
person in the long run so identify your
strengths and weakness that would be the
number one step uh not only in terms of
Behavioral interviews but also in terms
of on your day-to-day activities and
daily self-reflection because with that
over the course course of a certain
period of few weeks or even few years
you would become a significantly better
person in your work ethic in your
day-to-day activity and also as an
effective leader Mentor or a team
coworker so always have that habit next
you need to make sure that you reflect
on your relevant past experiences
because for any single behavioral
interview they're always going to dive
deeper into the questions regarding what
what have you done in the past what type
of challenges you fac how did you came
up with that what was your achievement
um what did you learn from it how can
you self- improve how can you teach
other how can you maybe create impact
for your customer these are going to be
the broader type of scenarios that you
would be asked on and you would be
judged on so a quick question or a quick
tip whenever you are working or whatever
the experiences you have faced in your
career so far just start making good
points or good stories in some piece of
paper so that would allow you to have
those talking points when you actually
get to that stage in actual behavioral
interview because many times in uh any
behavioral interview they are going to
be asking you somewhere between 4 to 10
or somewhere between 5 to 20 Questions
depending on how lengthy the interview
are what type of difficulties they wants
to have and what type of questions they
are suggesting now for these questions
uh you don't want to repeat the same
story or same scenario again and again
and again it would make really good
impact if you can have different
scenarios and different considerations
for all the things you did so that is
going to play out in your favor so but
but many times it becomes really
difficult to recall all of these things
on the go when you are actually in that
interview so it's always better to
prepare beforehand have have all of
those experiences noted down maybe you
can create some short bullet points for
your star method uh you can say that
okay uh the situation was that a manual
deployment was getting out of hand and
we were we were having a lot of issues
uh task was that you needed to deploy
something really quickly and it needed
to be in the production as soon as
possible the action you took is that you
started working on the automated devops
deployment scenario on the side uh you
took care of the high priority items
immediately and the low priority items
you refrained from pushing to the
production and then you kept them aside
and then first you build that those
automated cicd pipelines and then in the
end you deploy everything uh using cicd
Pipeline and as a result now you are
seeing that all the deployments in your
company are happening automatically
using the automated deployments so this
can be one of the examples so so in this
scenario you can write bullet points as
situation manual deployments task maybe
deploy something to production and also
uh build cicd pipelines action you
started building cicd pipelines and
result all the things became uh
automated what were the challenges you
find so you can add few more points for
that so I would personally suggest to
create at least 15 or 20 experiences
based on different scenarios that you
have faced in your career or you faced
on a day-to-day basis and just note them
down somewhere and have that have it
ready because once you have those
experiences you the moment you would see
them and you would understand that okay
these are the things I've already done
it becomes really easy to convey that in
an actual interview that it would then
it wouldn't even feel like an interview
it would feel like a normal conversation
between two people where you are just
going over all the experiences you face
and it would be like remember when when
during this time this was the situation
this is how we dealt with it and it was
pretty fun and I learned this and I
learned this and from based on this this
experience next time I wouldn't repeat
this so it it can be a great exercise to
reflect on the the relevant experiences
that you have currently face so far and
that brings us to our next point that is
once you realize uh that what are your
strengths and weaknesses once you have
those stories ready now when you come
closer towards the actual interview
start diving deep into the true
requirements of any particular job you
are applying for understand what type of
seniority for that job is understand
that what type of requirements the
company is having uh in every single job
description companies mention that what
would be the generic technical skills
needed on top of it what would be the
day-to-day basis or duties or behavioral
skills required maybe you have to deal
with external customer so you need some
sales experience maybe you need to deal
with a team of large uh individuals
maybe you need to lead a team of
different people maybe you need to
behave as like a a tech lead or a senior
lead uh in in any particular position so
realize that what job description is
suggesting to and then reflect on the
relevant experiences you had try to
create mapping between all the things
that you have done and you have learned
so far and make sure that not to ignore
the the job description and ask the same
questions to either the hiring manager
or your recruiter beforehand that what
type of expectation the company is
having is there anything about the
company culture that should I know
before you go deeper into the behavioral
interview because this is going to give
you a great insight and idea about what
type of questions that you can be judged
on or you can be asked and maybe you can
have those specific experiences ready uh
because that comes in handy for some
different companies because many
companies they have a very specific set
of culture and they need very specific
set of individuals with the correct
mindset and we will learn more about
that in the upcoming case studies that
we are going to study but make sure that
once you have the strengths weakness and
self-reflection you have these story
points and then you go very deep into
the job requirements so that you have
that matching criteria or matching
Matrix between what is needed and what
you currently have so it becomes pretty
easy and your odds of success in in the
interview becomes exponentially High
next you will you should never ignore
the company culture and Company values
that a company
tend to behave on and and thrive on most
of the scenario what I have personally
felt is every single company tend to
have a similar work structure where they
wants to do what's best for the company
what's best for their customer what's
best for their employees they wants to
build product more efficiently more
securely more reliably they wants to
have people who work in accordance with
each other who are not having any like
lot of significant issues they try to
work as a fine-tune machine and uh uh as
a well-built team where everyone is
trusting each other to complete the job
done and if someone is lacking behind
then they want other people to push that
person forward because we are only as
strong as the weakest link so they wants
to take all the employees to do better
because companies have realized after a
lot of research and lot of investing and
lot of uh Consulting with lot of big big
and small companies that if the
employees are happy and if you have like
true leaders and true connections
amongst the employees they tend to drive
the project and team forward and I can
give you an example for that see any
open-source project there is no
motivation for anyone to work in that
open source project because they are not
incentivized in terms of compensation
they are not incentivized in terms of
any recognition or any monetary gains
but still those products have
significantly changed the world think of
WI edia it is a community-driven
community build people build entire
software or ecosystem that has helped
millions of people all across world and
it is all being done just because people
are passionate about that that overall
game or or overall goal and it's a
rewarding mechanism that comes with
being recognized of doing something
great or good or doing something better
for the world and that feeling enables
people to achieve something more and
same thing companies wants to develop in
their own employees that's why you see
all of these big companies they are
trying to give all of these perks and
these benefits to their employees
because they realize that if the
employees are happy and if they are not
distracted they would build products
that is going to take the company uh all
the way off the charts so for sure
research that any specific company you
are applying for what type of culture
they possess what are the key values
that they have and that's where the
conversation with recruiter the
conversation with hiring manager maybe
some ex employees that comes in handy
maybe read through some blogs try to go
on and search on YouTube if that company
is popular enough maybe someone has
posted some videos about what type of
work work culture they have and how do
they promote it and how you can leverage
yourself for that interview for that any
particular company so these are going to
be really important mechanism plus you
can also see that okay company has these
important values and these are my
personal values and these are my
personal experience once again you have
better matching answers for those uh
questions when they come in during your
behavioral interview now let's we are
going to see a very interesting case
study this is one of the most popular
case studies and it's for the company
Netflix and honestly Netflix has one of
the most unique cultures that I have
seen in any company so that's why I
really wanted to discuss about Netflix
Netflix at some point decided that we
are going to treat all of our employees
as Elite Sport team we are not just
going to have them as normal employees
and one thing you know about Elite
sports team is that number one all
players they work for the good of the
team number two every single player has
to be on the top of their game and if
someone is slacking or someone is
lacking behind coaches tend to push them
forward give them honest opinion honest
reviews make sure that they are working
the best they can they are achieving the
best they can and you know what like
right now Netflix started hiring some
recent graduate but a couple of years
back until then they only had one level
throughout their entire company and that
was senior software developer of course
different people would report to
different people and depending on
seniority there would be some pay
differences but still Netflix would pay
the high highest amount of salary
amongst all the companies in the US they
they at some point they were paying
somewhere around like
$565,000 that was the average salary for
every single employee or every single
engineer at Netflix so imagine more than
half a million dollar for an engineer
which means their compensation or their
monetary problems has completely gone
number two Netflix is one of the only
companies that does not believe in
giving bonuses that they their mentality
is that we don't promote have providing
bonus because uh we know that we are
providing them enough things that they
don't have to keep running forward for
that bonus but they would rather do good
throughout the year without the
incentive of bonus because they are
already extremely well paid plus next
thing is that they have the option to
receive the entire salary whether in
cash or just as base salary or if they
wants they can they control that whether
they wants like 10% stocks 20% stock 50%
stocks which is pretty cool because if
you see any other company like maybe
Google Facebook Microsoft any other
company they have a very strict stock
vesting schedule and um they decide how
you are going to get paid but Netflix is
like we treat our employees like adults
we know that they are going to do what's
good for them and what's good for
Netflix what's good for their their
company and we are going to treat them
as elite elite sports players so they
have this Elite Sports mentality where
every single player is responsible to
bring team forward bring team up they
are going to be extremely well
compensated they have unlimited paid
time off they have unlimited benefits
lot of cool perks and stuff and
everything like that on top of it they
decided that they're going to be fully
Cloud they're always going to be cutting
edge Innovative they are going to do the
best thing possible and they have
already achieved that which is quite
quite insignificant uh and the other
thing is that not only being a Elite
Sport team they're also be going to be
thoroughly honest with their employees
and what do I mean by thoroughly honest
they have a very strong feedback culture
uh every single time every single
meeting or maybe any project if you're
doing something good you are doing
something bad you are doing something
horrible you are going to get an honest
feedback and you are going to get it
immediately and it doesn't even matter
that maybe you are you just joined in
and you are at slightly junior level
position and compared to someone who has
been in Netflix for 10 years if you see
that that person is making some mistake
they actually Pro encourage you to that
you should go ahead and reach out to
that person and honestly tell them that
these are the mistakes you are doing and
this would be my feedback and this is
how you can make it better and they
really appreciate that feedback culture
so even if you interview at Netflix uh
let's say that you did not get a job for
some reason they're going to be very
honest with you that hey these are the
things we asked these are the mistakes
you made this is our feedback maybe it
can help you out in the future but
currently we cannot move forward with
that and that mentality makes Netflix
what it is today one of honestly Netflix
has been a disruptor they have created
an entire industry of online streaming
it was one of the only Services now they
have this very interesting Keepers test
and what does keeper test mean is that
managers are only being asked one
question and that question is that if
this person in your team decides to
leave Netflix today are you going to
fight to keep that person and if the
answer is yes that's great that that
person is doing his job his or her job
very well but if manager manager answers
that no I would not fight to keep that
person and I would let that person go if
that is the case Netflix would by
default let that person go they would be
like we don't want to wait for you to
decide that I want to leave Netflix if
you are not performing at the level or
at the Elite Sports level we don't want
you in the Netflix and of course they
are going to give you Hefty severance
package and they have all of these cool
benefits so that's the thing that's that
is such a unique thing about Netflix
that they have a very unique Sports
mentality they have a very unique keeper
test and the feedback culture so if I'm
I preparing for a Netflix interview I'm
going to keep these things in mind I and
I will pick the experiences I had where
I had to give someone honest feedback or
take someone's honest feedback and then
work on myself and improve myself and
improve the system and do the good for
the company so I'm going to do all of
these things because I studied and I
realized that this is the culture
Netflix is promoting so you need to
understand that how these companies work
and if you realize their their work
culture you can actually be in a very
good position for yourself to secure
that job now let's talk about the second
case study that is Amazon now Amazon has
always been a topic of conversation
amongst Tech
Engineers lot of people really like
Amazon a lot of people hate Amazon they
have lot of different products and lot
of different teams and they are they are
one of the biggest tech companies in the
world that's for sure
now the thing is Amazon also has a very
unique culture and very unique set of
skills and personal values the different
thing about Amazon is that they actually
believe in something called leadership
principles and few years back Amazon
came up with these uh huge list of
different leadership principles and they
say that every single employee needs to
follow these leadership principles in
order to be counted as a successful
candidate at Amazon so some of the
leadership principles are I have listed
over here that it's like customer
Obsession becoming the earth's best
employer or think big how can you
deliver results pretty quickly and a lot
of other things now the thing is if you
are applying or if you are preparing for
Amazon I would definitely recommend you
to go over these leadership principles
maybe create one or two examples for
each principal because you are not going
to be asked all 16 of the principles but
most likely throughout your six or seven
rounds of interview you would we ask at
least somewhere between four to 10
different leadership principles and it
wouldn't be that hey tell me an example
about think b or tell me an example
where you have to earn the trust it
wouldn't be directly but the question
would be framed around these leadership
principles and then there would be
followup questions on the answers you
would give so if I'm preparing for
Netflix I would prepare for the answers
based on like keepers say feedback
culture how I Chang the company or how I
brutally honest how do I work work with
the team or how do I work with the upper
stakeholders or whatnot if I'm preparing
something for like Amazon I would
prepare on leadership principles I would
create some examples for each one of
them I would reflect on myself and this
is how you can prepare beforehand so
that it's going to be very helpful for
your upcoming jobs or upcoming
interviews now you know the interesting
thing is you only need to prepare once
because if let's say that Amazon has 16
leadership principles if you prepare all
the answers for each one of the
leadership principles even tomorrow if
you go to some other company maybe
Microsoft or maybe Google if they ask
some questions you would still be able
to answer even if you didn't prepare why
because these are the common qualities
that's going to cover the majority or
most common part so that's why I'm
saying that all you need to do the
preparation part for behavioral
interview is quite easy and quite simple
all you need need to do is just realize
what are your strengths realize where
you need to improve what are your
weaknesses do uh
self-reflection note down all the
experiences and then do the research
about the job you are trying to apply
and then maybe learn something about the
company culture and curate your answer
using the star method okay now let's
talk about the different categories of
behavioral interview questions so number
one category is teamwork that companies
wants to know that how easily and how
efficient ly can you work within a team
and are you like a teamwork kind of
person or not next one is a problem
solving skills so if something some
ingenuine problem occurs some unexpected
scenario arise are you able to deal with
that or not next category is
adaptability are you able to adapt to a
new situation a new scenario how easily
can you adjust and what are the things
you need to do next one is the
communication and the last category is
the leadership now leadership categories
typically Ally reserve for people higher
up in the experience chain but still
even if you are at the junior level
still you can be asked some questions
regarding leadership and you can give
examples based on the small amount of
experience you have gain or maybe some
of the projects you did outside of your
actual job uh maybe during your
University you had some initiatives and
you can define leadership over there so
there can be different scenarios now
let's try to understand each category uh
by its own by some of the key point
points that are associated with that
category and then we will start diving
deeper into the 50 behavioral questions
so number one category is teamwork and
collaboration now the companies wants to
check that how easily can you cooperate
with the person uh are you the person
who is open-minded to different
scenarios do you have the empathy to
understand what other person in the team
is going through how can you make the
best out of the bad situation how can
you take everyone together uh how can
others leverage from the work you are
doing or how can you leverage the work
that others are doing uh can you
collaborate with other people or other
teams or other members new members or
maybe some senior fellow all of these
kinds of things they wants to ensure
next one is the problems solving skills
so obviously with the rapid change in
the world every single day new problem
arise or maybe 10 new problems arise and
you need to have the critical thinking
to make the changes on top of it you
need to have some sort of creativity in
generating the problem Sol or solving
the problem uh you need rigorous
analysis skills to analyze that what is
the current situation what you have done
in the past what have worked what has
not worked how can you make the best out
of the bad situation how can you
convince other stakeholders about the
problem if you have identified some new
problems how what should be your
approach how can you take on it if
something is much more complicated very
difficult how would you work upon that
uh so there are lot of things you have
to con consider and rationally come up
with the reasoning in order to solve the
problem in the efficient manner so there
would for sure there would be some
questions regarding the problem solving
in your behavioral interview next one is
the adaptability are you a person who is
flexible enough to change uh can you be
resilient um in the face of adversity if
there are some completely unexpected
items are happening are you able to come
up cope up with that uh if there are new
new changes new policies or new rules
that you have to abide by how quickly
can you manage them if you have to learn
some new skills do you have the right
attitude to basically take on something
completely new that you knew nothing
about and still you dive deeper into
that and uh build the solutions around
that new piece of technology because it
industry is continuously changing it's a
very frugal industry and everyday new
technology or new system or new problems
comes in and you have to be adaptable
towards solving them best example lock
4G everyone knows that the lock 4G
vulnerability probably one of the most
popular libraries that was used all
across world and suddenly everyone had
to change that their version and then
everyone had to be adaptable on how
quickly can you change the version how
quickly can you adapt the vulnerability
and that raised lot of questions on how
resilient your systems are how can you
make the that Improvement how can you
significantly change change those
processes and that sort of thing and the
last one or the second last one is
communication because of course
communication is one of the very key
skills that you need in order to succeed
at your job I'm not saying that everyone
should be proficient in maybe English or
French or some other language whichever
language you speak it doesn't matter as
long as you can convey your thoughts in
a profound Manner and you are well
articulate in sort of the words you use
or the way you uh communicate with all
the different people you need to be
clear concise in your thought and in
your communication and it should not be
vague generic kind of things be specific
be on point give clear examples and uh
that is going to help you tremendous in
your career on top of that one of the
key important parts for any
communication skills is actually active
listening or mindful listening that you
need to be in the moment and understand
that what is the exact scenario and for
for them
rather than just proving your point or
throwing your point you will actually
have to listen first and if you develop
this ability it's going to significantly
improve your odds in being not only
being successful at any interview but
also being success greatly successful at
your company because great leaders also
tend to be great listeners as well so
make sure you do that and you are
articulate in your thought process and
uh the way you answer different things
on top of it believe it or not there is
always going to be some level of
bureaucracy in any different company and
in order to take come up come across
that you will have to be diplomatic you
will have to understand that what are
the tradeoffs you can make what is going
to be the give and take in this
situation how can you make the most
optimal or most efficient approach and
for that you need to have some sort of
diplomatic personality or diplomacy in
your
workings because let's say that you are
given two problems and you uh both seems
urgent at the moment but you can only do
one so which one will you pick can you
how can you make that judgment call uh
what are the constraints you are going
to consider what are going to be your uh
pros and cons for picking one over the
other what is going to make that
assumption clear concise and how would
you communicate that with the team that
you are going you are saying essentially
no to that hey I won't be able to work
on this right now how would you be able
to communicate that for that you need uh
the skills of diplomacy and make sure
that that you uh work upon that and last
one is leadership so as I mentioned
leadership is one of the most important
qualities because without a strong
leader um no company can Thrive and uh
that's why the higher up you are in your
experience level and the better sort of
positions you are applying for they are
going to be keen on focused on the
leadership that how can you help people
under you how can you help with the
different responsibilities can you
handle uh various portfolios can you
handle team of different people can you
handle uh an individual who is a tough
person to handle how do you promote your
team how do you motivate others so all
of these kinds of things they are going
to come into the picture that can you
take new initiatives are you going to be
a responsible person are you going to be
accountable for the things that is that
are currently happening and how how can
you make it more resilient what would be
your contribution on Mo promoting others
motivating others so make sure that you
you need to have leadership qualities as
well but this vastly depends on the
people with higher levels of
experience okay so now we are going to
talk about the most important topic for
this entire course that is 50 different
behavioral interview questions and we
are going to discuss each one of them in
a very good detail now before we start
diving deeper into the questions first
let's understand few things very clearly
number one I have taken 10 questions
from each of the five different
categories that we just talk about which
means uh you are going to get a
comprehensive list of all almost all
sorts of questions based on all of these
five categories and these are the main
categories that you are going to be
judged upon because majority majority of
the companies they are looking for a
specific mindset that is going to be
like uh involved with different teams
very good at to at communication at
leadership at problem problem solving
and things like that so most of the
questions would be typically covered by
these 50 questions and even if you might
not get the exact same wording as the
question the intent is going to be same
so for each of the question that we are
going to discuss about I also urge you
that at the same time you also try to
create your own answer for each one of
the questions I'm not saying that for
all 50 questions write down the answer
and then mug up all the answers but in
your mind you should have some idea that
hey if I counter this question this is
going to be the story or scenario or
experience I'm going to explain or if I
talk about or or if the that this is the
question maybe this could be the intent
behind the question so let me frame my
answer in that manner and for each of
the question once again go over the list
of experiences you have built upon so
far maybe I explained like have
somewhere between 10 to 20 experiences
that are different from each other and
that should cover or that should broadly
show the good sides of the things that
you have been through and maybe even if
there were some challenging situations
what were you able to learn from that so
have that list ready create a star
formatted bullet points I'm not saying
that have all the entire 45 second
answer written on some document because
that's that's going to take a lot of
time just have some bullet points and be
open to discussion and be in the moment
so these are going to be some advises
and last thing I would like to say is
that any question you are going to be
asked in an interview be prepared that
there are going to be at least three to
five follow-ups depending on the
interviewer and depending on how dep in
depth the answer you give so for sure
for any single question they are going
to they must have prepared some
follow-up questions that they are going
to ask you some followup will occur from
your own answer so it's also in your
handle hand that which direction you
want to take your answer or next
question into so you can also tweak that
depending on the current answer you give
but more or or less be prepared for the
followup and once again I'm giving you
uh an honest opinion don't try to fake
answers in an interview if you haven't
faced any exact specific situation just
be honest and say that I never had to
face this exact situation in my past but
if I have to solve this this would be my
approach this takes you way further than
if you just try to make some random
story and then you get caught with the
facts and then they ask you followups
and you are not able to give the answer
and then they would realize that you are
essentially bluffing your way into it
okay so now I have given you the
introduction about what is going to be
the format and expectation for these
questions now let's start with the type
of questions okay so number one topic we
are going to select is going to be
teamwork and collaboration so let's talk
about question number one this is give
an example of a challenging and
successful team project that you were
part of and then for this question
prepare for a follow-up question or also
at this can also be part of the same
question that what made it successful
and what made it challenging now this is
a an question with lot of different
moving dimensions and uh perspectives
number one thing is you need to explain
that uh a type of Team project that you
were in so maybe you can give some some
more information about what type of team
were there maybe there were multiple
teams involved what was your
contribution what were you are trying to
achieve next you need to focus on the
challenging parts that that what was the
challenging scenario for this type of
exact uh uh experience that you are
describing maybe there were tight
deadlines maybe there were some U
existing product issues that needed to
be fixed on an immediate basis maybe
there was some Priority One or priority
to incident that happened and that needs
to be resolved in the moment for and in
order to resolve that many teams are
working maybe there is a threat coming
from the outside and you have to deal
with it if not company is essentially
losing money every single day so there
can be many different challenges for any
particular projects maybe there is a
challenge related to Tex Tech maybe
there is a challenge related to number
of resources maybe you don't have
sufficient technology maybe you don't
have sufficient amount of money that you
can spend for the project and then you
have to make the choices according to
that there are lot of different
challenging situations but now on top of
being a challenging situation you will
also to explain that how was it a
successful project so typical
definitions of sub success is on time
and on budget these are to these tend to
be the standard definition but on top of
it in order for a successful team team
project you can also explain that how
did your team learn from that how did
you completed that how did you change
the ways of how things happens in your
company and this became like a a
framework for all the subsequent
projects so this this was uh in in
itself an key Inception project in your
journey this can be a very good ch
question to ask at the beginning because
this is going to open up so many
different questions and so many
different follow-ups plus it will give
you a great contribu great way to shine
as well for sure after this question
they are going to focus more on that
what were the responsibilities of the
team what were your responsibilities
what were your contribution so always
whenever you are giving answer related
to teamwork or different team projects
make sure that you clearly Define the
distinction of what was your specific
duties because they are only interested
in your attitude your behavior and the
things you had to do and things you
learn so you can give the broad example
of the whole scenario and then start
putting more emphasis on what you were
responsible for and how did you behave
in this situation okay now let's go to
the second question that is tell me a
time when you had to deal with a
difficult client or a difficult coworker
so once again the question is open to
interpretation difficult client
difficult coworker you can give an
example of each one of them this is a
very common scenario maybe you are
working in a company or where you are
directly dealing with the client or you
are in some sort of consultant position
so you you have to work with lot of
different companies or vendors or
engagements and maybe something happened
why where why the client was being
difficult what was the overall scenario
you need to explain all of these things
now let me first give you an example of
a difficult client then I'll give you an
example for the difficult difficult
coworker okay for the difficult client
you can talk about that uh what made
them trigger maybe they were unhappy
with your company from the beforehand
maybe they didn't like the products of
your company maybe they had some
competitor who was providing a better
deal maybe you were not responding to
their queries so you can say that yeah
this was the difficult situation the
client was not personally difficult
towards you but overall this was the
situation and they were not willing to
uh move forward with the solution so the
approach can be that you explained you
reached out to them you try to listen
that what were their exact concerns you
gave them a time frame on the potential
fixes and make sure that you you stayed
on that time frame and you committed
towards that and in the end you are able
to finally come up with a solution this
can be a way to deal with any difficult
client or Co client and in order to deal
with difficult coworker of course this
is a very common scenario now for the
difficult coworker you will have to
understand that why the coworker is
being difficult towards you maybe that
person is just the the way that they are
that they are always behaving like that
with everyone else or is there any
specific bias against you or they are
just being mean towards you so make sure
that that is the case if that is the
case always before taking any further
step steps or actions just make sure
that you reach and speak with the
coworker try to understand their
concerns why they are um why you feel
that they are being difficult towards
you and in my opinion this should be
this should mostly close out all the uh
differences that you might had so maybe
this can be a great way to move forward
and if not you can also try to involve
your manager or your pro project manager
if things get to that level but needless
to say so this can be your answer in
order to uh explain this type of
scenario now let's move on to the next
question can you describe a time when
you had to deal with a team member who
wasn't pulling their weight so I
actually faced this kind of situation in
one of my previous roles and I can give
you my experience so we were working on
a project and uh we realized that one of
the uh one of the de other developers
they were not fulfilling their
commitments towards the task that they
were being assigned to and then that was
causing a strain on the existing project
so it in that developer was reasonably
good like there were no issues with him
but suddenly he started doing that so I
reached out to him I asked him hey what
is the issue is there something wrong
that is going on um why you are not able
to do that and I asked that asked that
in in a personal meeting and I realized
that one of very close family members of
that particular coworker was actually
really sick and um was in a very
critical condition in the hospital so
that coworker was pretty stressed about
that situation of that family member
maybe um like fighting for the life and
death in in the hospital and that was
causing him all sorts of anxiety issues
plus uh because that family member
staying in the hospital the overall
responsibilities were way too much he
will have to he had to manage everything
at home and then everything at the
hospital and then traveling here and
there and medicines and uh extra
expenses and whatnot so I learned that
this was the situation I asked him that
do you want me to speak with the project
manager or uh team manager and he was
like yeah maybe we can talk about it we
discussed the situation and the managers
were like you take couple of weeks off
don't worry about the work just take
care of your family uh nothing comes
more important so they gave him that
that freedom on our side like all all of
us our team members we distributed the
work that that coworker was do doing and
then we dealt with that situation now
the thing is the first in Instinct for
us was to blame everything that this
person is not able to do the work but we
realized that there was a very specific
reason that why they were not able to
pull up pull their weight because they
were under this this unexpected scenario
and then once that coworker came back he
was pretty happy that the team supported
him in that hardship time and then once
the things resolved that employee was
back on the performance so this this was
a really good learning experience that
many times if you just communicate well
you you might understand and many times
you might not know the whole story on
why things are the way they are so
always try to find the that that exact
thing or exact reason first before you
start judging them or you start taking
harsher or more stricter actions or
where you start to U escalate things
okay so this was uh this can be one of
the examples this is how I would give
the answer maybe like slightly shorter
not so long but you get the idea right
same way you can also create your own
your own experience your own story how
would you deal with it if the team you
realiz that the team member after having
many Communications still is not pulling
their weight and still being lazy or
slacker then you might have to escalate
the issue you might have to uh take some
responsibilities off of them because you
don't want to je jeopardize the project
just because one team member is not
doing their job okay next is how do you
handle a situation where you had to
disagree with a supervisor again this is
going to be one of the most popular
questions because most of the interviews
I have been asked this question so
that's why you also uh sort of be
prepared for this well essentially
whenever you have a disagreement with
your supervisor manager project manager
anyone number one what was the reason
what where does the disagreement lies so
the example could be that uh maybe we
were trying to build out a new product
or a new project suddenly the company at
that time had the Mandate that
everything should be built in the cloud
and we were trying to migrate from on
premises to the cloud but this new
product that we were trying to build on
that that needed to be done in a very
quick Manner and if we had to go through
the cloud native route maybe it would
have taken us longer time so that's why
manager was like uh do this right now
deploy it on the on premises and then
maybe we can start thinking about Cloud
later so that was sort of the uh
approach from the manager uh on your
side you can say that you were proport
you were suggesting that rather than
doing double the effort maybe you can
just build it one one time and have it
Cloud native enabled so this is where
the agreement lied this was the
situation the background was company
wanted this thing your manager wanted
the product to ship out fast in the
fastest manner you wanted it to be done
properly by deploying into the cloud so
this was the dis disagreement how did
you handle the situation maybe you had a
communication with the with your manager
you explained the pros and Co cons or
you walk together on the pros and cons
of each each situation you realize that
what was his or her point of view what
is what was your point of view uh you
put both the things on the scale and
then with a common consensus you came to
a conclusion that okay this is this
would be the correct path forward and we
agree on this and then you move forward
and you implemented the solution and
then what was the result you can explain
that so this is a very good example of
you conveying that you are thinking
about what is going to be the best in
the long run you are also thinking about
that if you have a disag agreement with
your manager how you are going to
approach that how you are going to
convey your pros and cons for each one
of the things and what is your thought
process or your mechanism to come up
with the most ideal solution that is
going to be in agreement with all the
available stakeholders so this can be a
great uh questions question to ask in an
interview as well and expect that this
question might be somewhere down the
line okay next one is describe when you
had to use your understanding to lead a
team again now the question is this is
on the leadership side as well also
working with the team as well so if you
are already applying for like a
leadership position this question is
very evident they want you to understand
that what are your team leadership
abilities next thing is maybe if you're
not applying for a team leadership
position but still they want to
understand that if you are in a position
where you might have to lead a group of
people or different team what would what
would be your approach so once again you
can think of a scenario that why did you
have to lead the team how did you
started leading the team what was your
understanding of understanding of of
each one of the team members how would
you how did you approach them how did
you approach the conflicting views how
did you approach the conflicting
priorities uh how did you approach or
how did you convey each one of them to
stay motivated so these are all the
dimensions that are going to be asked
for this question so for sure you can
think of a a scenario where maybe you
might not be leading the team but
suddenly you realize that one of your
coworker uh they were out on a holiday
or vacation who tend to be at a senior
position and then now you are in a
situation where you had to get this task
done uh with the priority basis so how
did you convince other how did you reach
out to different teams how did you
convey the result to the stakeholders
and how did you keep the communication
going on on top of it staying up to date
on the task that you are trying to
finish okay so explain like this and it
would be it would look really good for
for uh your U answer next question is uh
can you talk about a time when you had
to coordinate with different departments
to complete a project once again pretty
standard question and always in many
projects you are going always going to
be working with uh many different teams
uh simultaneously because some team is
working on transac like half part of the
transaction you might be working on the
other half there might be some other
team who is working on the third part
and whatnot so how how did you keep the
communication alive what are your points
of contacts how do you do some
collaborative activities how do you
build trust between the different teams
if there is any problem arises how do
you deal with different teams uh how do
you note down everything how do you keep
track of things how do you keep track of
timetable uh what are going to be your
responsibilities uh working cross
functionally with the team if there are
conflicting priorities how you are going
to keep track of that so these are all
the things that you can think of
considering now next question is tell me
about a time when you had to rely on
your presentation skills to influence
someone's opinion so maybe you might be
in a sales type position where you have
to sell something or you have to
convince a client to maybe buy your
product or uh understand the importance
of the product so that that is where
your presentations and skills can come
into play maybe you find some technical
issue in your existing system and you
can you need to explain that situation
to all the other stakeholders in the
existing company so even though the
thing might be technical but many times
you might have to explain the situation
to to some business level people who are
not so technical maybe you have to
explain it to your junior team who might
not have all the entire idea of the
whole ecosystem or whole project so
depending on what type of stakeholder
you are trying to explain your
presentation needs to change and the way
you are going to approach the things
also needs to change so if you explain
like this that for in order to solve one
problem you have to so present the
solutions to three different teams in
three different ways and this are going
to be your approaches for each one of
them and this is how you are going to
convey them that this is why we need to
do this and if they decide to do it if
you have some sort of like example like
this in your past maybe this can be a
great question to Showcase that not only
you think think depending on who you are
speaking with you are also coming up
with different approaches and different
solutions
based on the person you are speaking
with or the the problem you are trying
to solve so that's a great uh skill to
have uh and any company would want a
person to be to have that kind that type
of attitude next question is describe a
situation where you had to resolve an
interpersonal conflict at work so if
there is a conflict going on between two
members of the team how would you
resolve that if you realize that there
is a conflict going on between two
different teams because many times like
the the two teams had to work really
close but also when an issue happens
there is a lot of finger pointing
between both the teams and that's why
they they might have some disgruntled
previous experience that uh they have
some issues going on between those those
two teams and uh that amongst these type
of scenarios how would you approach it
if you have that that experience in your
past always feel free to throw out if
you don't have that experience you can
also say that I have never personally
experienced this but if I experience a a
situation or a question like this my
Approach would be to First realize that
what is the root cause of problem why
they are being hostile or uh in
disagreement with each other or why they
it feels like there is always a conflict
going on and then once you realize the
root of the problem you start to
eradicate that problem and start to work
upon the solutions so that that can be
one of the good good approaches to take
on the question like this next one is
how do you approach working in a diverse
and inclusive environment now this
question is like a free hit or like a an
open goal or penalty goal like that for
sure the real simple fact is diverse and
inclusive teams are always going to be
far more Superior than a single type of
teams and there is a very clear study
for that let me give you an example back
in like' 60s or' 7s when the the team
where they start the auto manufacturing
company they started building these
dummy models that would be put in the
cars and then cars would be placed in a
in an a crash like scenario so the
purpose was to see that how would the
dummies behave and they wanted to make
cars safer and safer now initially at
that point of time all the engineers or
all the scientists who were working on
building the dummies they created a
dummy based on a male European average
uh person so the dummy was in terms of
height shape Dimensions was treated as
if that that person would be like a a
European a average European male what it
turned out is because of this and this
was not an intentional thing this was
just a random consensus they came up
with uh because all the the most of the
group of scientists were male European
and they thought that this is a common
body type that every human on the world
has so they started creating building
the dummies then they started testing
the cars against all those crash
collision scenarios and realized that
okay these are the safety features that
cars have to adopt because this is what
we experienced based on the dummies just
because of that one
bias despite cars having those added
extra features it was not safe for
children it was not safe for women it
was not safe for uh people from
different places of the world maybe like
Asian people or African people or
something like that
so even though they were trying to do a
good thing a very Noble thing but just
because while considering the crash
dummies they did not consider the whole
ecosystem of different people and
different types of uh humans that are
present they ended up being the reason
for lot of deaths of course they saved
lot of people I'm not saying that their
work does not send any value but had
they had more inclusive team maybe there
were like more women maybe there were
people from different parts of the world
I'm pretty sure someone would have said
at that time that hey instead of
creating a dummy like this why don't we
create four different types of dummies
to represent more set of people and then
we can do all of these tasty like safety
test on on the cars and that would have
saved lot many lives so this is why if
you give like this example in your
interview your interviewer will will
start crying because it's a it's a a
true story on how an inclusive team can
make a significant difference in a
project or a product or the thing you
are trying to build because everyone has
different backgrounds everyone has
different experiences different ways
that they grew up maybe they belong to
different company countries cultures uh
different ethnicities different colors
their perspective are going to be golden
if you have someone in a company who
thinks like me then why do you have that
person if both things are thinking alike
then there is something wrong of keeping
both things in in both people so that's
why Always whenever you think you see
anything about diversity and inclusion
always always be on the Forefront be the
be an inclusive person that that always
makes the world a better place now next
thing is can you give me an example of
how you motivated others so if I have to
give this example I can give in couple
of ways maybe I can talk about a time
where uh I had to work on a project and
we were working against tight deadlines
and then we realized that we were short
staff so I reached I found these interns
at my company and the interns were
recently joined so I reached out to the
to the interns that hey if you want to
work on something cool because they had
the time and resource at their hand but
they did not head the direction and then
I reached out to management that hey I
have I have found these people they are
willing to work with me uh can I have
your permission and once doing that I
started teaching them helping them
motivating them on what we are trying to
do and once we achieved the whole thing
as a result I received my promotion and
all the interns they received like
full-time hire offer from the company
that you are working for and this is a
true story so this is a great way I just
motivated them because I explained them
that this is a new thing that we are
trying to do it has Major Impact it is
going to be important from the company's
perspective plus it is a really nice
skill to learn and by doing so you will
gain much more real life experience on
how things happens and how things are
operating at a team plus I gained
experience on mentoring different people
and uh creating more friendships so that
was a win win for everyone and this was
my example so this this can this can be
one of the ways I can say I have
motivated others maybe you could have
motivated someone else in some different
fashion maybe to take that leap in their
career maybe to take that leap in the
new technology or new thing that they
are trying to build maybe help them to
motivate them to become healthier in in
their lives even though it's not
technical still it is motivating other
people to do something nice for
themselves that can have lasting impact
so anything like this you can explain in
in your situation okay now let's talk
about the second category that is
problem solving and let's see question
number 11 describe a project where you
had to use your problem solving skills
so for this question number one thing is
why did you had to use your problem
solving skills what were the problem you
were trying to to solve maybe it was a
technical problem may maybe it was a
mathematical problem that no one had
solution to maybe it was a problem with
different attitudes and shifting
priorities where you had to be really
creative in order to find the best path
forward and bring everyone um into the
consensus so all of these things you can
think about as why you had to be in that
situation and after realizing this
tricky situation what solution you came
up with how did you use the problem
solving approach how did you convince
other that your solution is correct and
then what was the end result you
achieved so this can be a pretty good
way to explain that how do you think on
different uh aspects and different
scenarios okay next one is tell me about
a time when you made a mistake and how
did you handle it no one in their
careers move forward without making many
mistakes so always make sure that you
must have made some mistakes at some
point in time then explain that what was
the mistake you made why did you make
that maybe you did not had enough
background knowledge maybe you did not
had experience maybe you did not learn
how to do that maybe the person teaching
you also didn't realize that how this
can be one of the odd case scenario
where this this issue can happen what
was the impact of the mistake how did
you own the mistake where you be like
yeah I'm accountable for my mistakes
this is my Approach and this is how I
take uh this is what I did now let me do
this to fix it and did you fix it after
fixing it what did you learn how did you
convince others not to make the same
mistake so these are all the things that
you can think about while creating an
answer for how like tell me about a time
when you had to handle a mistake okay
next one is describe a situation where
you had to be particularly attentive to
details how did you handle that once
again now you will start seeing a
pattern about all the questions that we
are discussing that whenever you say
that you have to be particularly
attentive number one question
why did you had to be attentive maybe it
was a very critical thing maybe you are
working with sensitive data maybe you
are working on a sensitive product
critical timelines maybe uh you or your
your team had already tried to do this
and you already failed like couple of
times so this time you have to make sure
that this was the way this was the way
you have to move forward so you have to
make sure that you don't make any
mistakes after explaining the scenario
now how did you ensure that you are
being particularly attentive maybe you
can do like that after completing the
whole thing you did couple of times
extra reviews to make sure you did not
miss something maybe you try to use some
automated tools to realize that uh what
you are suggesting is correct or not
maybe you had it peer reviewed maybe you
reached out to your manager for the
feedback maybe you reached out to the
team for the feedback before presenting
it to a broader a audience or started
starting to build Solutions based on
that so these are the things you can
discl disclose about them next is can
you talk about a time when you had to
persuade others to see the things your
way why you had to pursue others that is
the background and now you understand
the point of whole questions okay why
did you have to persuade others what
were their approach and how your
approach was different how your approach
was going to be more sensible compared
to the other ones how did you explain
that to to them so can be a way where
you can show showcase your presentation
skills your persuasion abilities uh your
thinking abilities of thinking outside
the box uh treating the problem in a
different manner so same way like uh
American astronauts they build uh the
these like zero gravity pens uh that
despite costing million dollars it can
write at any angle but then Russian
scientists they they only use pencils it
was a a like 50 Cent solution and they
they saved millions of dollars so this
can be a different ways of different
solutions for the same problem okay so
now next let's go to the next question
tell me about a time when you should
initiative at work so initiative can be
anything initiative can be that uh maybe
you you showed an initiative to create a
new social activity at uh company maybe
you created like a new uh new tradition
at the company maybe you created a new
group of uh like parents of Highly
capable children in your company and
then you now you have like 500 members
and they they all share that what do
they do so that they can make their
children highly capable and now you have
created a great Initiative for the
diversity and inclusion also like
overall social social connection of the
of the company so that these these are
all parts of the initiatives next there
can be initiatives Rel related to
technical stuff that uh maybe you were
an on premise company you took the
initiative that the next product we are
trying to build let's build it in the
cloud and let's see that how what should
be our approach how cheap it is how
effective it is or maybe you already
have an existing ongoing system you try
to change some like alerting mechanism
you try to bring in uh automation devops
to the existing framework and that ended
up saving a lot of time but it still
took some initial time to build up and
then you you sort of took it upon
yourself with along with few other
people to be in that like initiate
initiation phase to get the things
rolling and uh start working on the
things so this can be a really good
approach next is describe a situation
where you had to take the lead on a
project so this is very similar to a
previous question we already discussed
but once again where did you like why
did you had to take the lead what was
the scenario how did you took the lead
uh maybe there was a problem specific
problem you are trying to solve and then
uh you put some extra attention in order
to achieve that result maybe some person
left the company some new project came
in some conf conflicting priorities
happen and then you are in the position
at the right place and the right time
and without passing the Buton to the to
someone else and saying that hey this is
not my responsibility someone else's
responsibility you took that initiative
and you Rose up to the situation you are
like no let me take care of this project
and I'm going to uh I'm going to do this
and I'm going to convince others to do
it along me so so this this can be a way
to show your problem solving skills and
your leadership abilities next one is
can you give me an example of a time
when you went above and beyond your job
duties now this is a tricky question
when you talk about above and beyond
your job duties number one of course you
want to give some examples maybe some
project or product you are really
passionate about and you are working on
it for 6 months that was coming close to
the deadline of launching to the
production so during that time you had
to put really extra ra focus and
attention to make sure that you go
through the production launch or release
in successful manner so for that you
might work like 2 weeks for like 12 hour
days and then uh in the end you made
sure that the whole release was
successful and then you were really
happy with all the progress you made and
maybe it was really beneficial to the
company so that's a that's a good good
way to acknowledge the scenario of going
above above and beyond but if you if you
see a scenario where for like
continuously 6 months every single day
you had to work like 12 or 14 hour days
in order to complete a work of course
you're going above and beyond but this
is not a sustainable way you are killing
yourself you are burning out you are
being less productive uh despite putting
more hours you are slowly and slowly
reducing your efficiency and you are not
maintaining the work life balance so you
are going to build up that resentment
towards the company eventually so always
be careful about what intensity you
define above and beyond okay now let's
go to the next one tell me about a time
when you had to innovate to solve a
problem once again why did you had to
innovate what type of problem it was
this question is more about the problem
being so in genuine that you have to
innovate something and what was your
Innovation uh how did you make things
easy how did you fix it and uh so yeah
the world is your oyster in this this
question so make sure like uh think
about your experiences uh and come up
with come up with some solution for that
okay next one is describe a time when
you had to make tough decisions quickly
how do you make tough decisions uh why
the decision was tough maybe a tough
example of tough decision is you might
have to let someone go layoffs that's a
very tough decision it can take toll on
any manager like no one wants to see
lives being destroyed but you have to
take it otherwise the company would go
under that can be a tough decision maybe
there can be a tough decision where
there is a a sity one production issue
going on and you have to decide that are
you going to fix it right away in which
you might have to tweak some rules that
that your company has set up or you are
going to go through the complete path
that is going to take maybe like couple
of hours extra so the solution would be
there but still for those couple of
hours is continuously losing money so
how do you make that decision how do you
do the calculated risk what is your
approach how do you keep the overall
team engage so think about these things
and come up with your own answers okay
next one is how do you approach learning
a new skills or technology provide an
example now change is the only constant
in it world every single year or every
couple of years new technologies come in
new libraries come in new text Tech new
problems new threats from the outside um
uh entities whatnot so you are always
always always going to be learning now
when this question is being asked it's
not more about that how do you learn it
it's about your approach towards
learning for learning something new so
your art of learning for learning a new
skill that is what you have to explain
and you can give lot of examples maybe
you had to some for any particular
project or product you have to learn a
new language maybe you jump companies in
your past and where in one company you
are working on maybe like AWS on the
other company you are working on Azure
so you have to learn relearn the whole
thing from scratch so there there can be
many examples just make sure that you
are being uh humble towards your
approach on learning uh what are the
different tools you take on and how do
you reach out to different people in the
team who might be junior to you but
still until you put your ego on the side
and you you go to them then and you ask
that hey I don't know about this thing
can you teach me can you explain me what
should be the potential solution so you
can talk about it now let's move on to
the next category and that is
adaptability so for that first let's see
that tell me about a time when you had
to adopt a significant change in the
workplace what was the significant
change why that change was came into the
place maybe one of the significant
change can be that previously let's
assume that all the deployments are
being done manually in like Dev QA uat
and production environment and suddenly
company came up with a mandate that
starting from next month everything has
to be automated with cicd you cannot do
anything manual and this is a big change
you are not used to it plus on top of it
you you will have to deal with your
existing workload plus you will have to
deal with this new uh cicd pipeline that
you will have to BU build so how would
how would you deal with it how would you
convince other team members to take part
of take part into this so understand
like this can be one of the examples but
you can you are feel free to create your
own example next one is describe a
situation where you had to gather
information from multiple sources how
did you determine which information is
most most relevant this is a very common
scenario because many like long running
projects they might have many versions
of
documentation and the current reality
would be completely different than what
is written in all of those
documentations because at some point
someone just stop updating the
documentation uh so now you have one
copy that says that hey things ABC are
correct you have another copy that says
that things XY Z is correct and maybe
you have some senior developer who says
that no the whole thing is actually 1 2
3 it's not even alphabets so how do you
correlate amongst all of these
information so the question is first of
all you try to regroup the whole all the
different information see that what are
the different points reach out to
different people in the team who might
have that idea that why the things are
are there the way they are if you are
still stuck and still not able to find
any solution maybe start digging into
the code base uh use some online tools
uh on like compilers that can run
through or iterate through through the
code and create these dependency graphs
see that what are the database being
connected how the transactions are
flowing through and then reverse
engineer that project uh and create the
documentation for for that I know it's a
much longer path but eventually it has
to be taken at some point if you want to
maintain the clear set of instructions
and then implement or create policies in
the company that this type of situation
does not occur in the future so now you
are maintaining the updated in relevant
information and what should be your
approach moving forward so this can be a
good example to explain next one is can
you talk about a time when you had to
work Under Pressure once again why you
had to work Under Pressure very you
fighting against dead tight deadlines
where you under staff under resource
where you working on some critical
project where you working on some
production issues that needed to be
fixed immediately uh did you miss some
deadlines um why did this happen so and
then what was your approach working
under pressure uh you realize that yeah
despite situation is intense do you want
to lose your productivity no so how what
should be your approach how would you
move forward uh what are the things you
would take into the consideration um how
would you help others in that situation
how do you keep the communication
channels alive and how do you calm
yourself how do what do you say to
yourself that hey uh we will get through
this let me think it like a rational
person without having so much of all of
these anxiety and panics in order to
complete that okay next one is how do
you handle meeting tight deadlines I
mean everyone must have experienced this
at some point if you if you have some
tight deadlines coming up make sure that
you prioritize the current work you have
if you have too much work on your plate
feel free to delegate that work or if
you cannot meet the deadline convey
beforehand to the consumers that why you
are not able to meet it what are the
reasonings what are going to be the new
timelines always assess that where your
current project is where it is heading
what are the timelines you predicted
where you are and what should be your
next next steps forward so if you
continuously do that I don't think you
would be in a situation where out of the
blue your project is like now 1 month
delay in the in terms of uh deadlines uh
so it would very rarely happens if you
already have all of these things present
so make sure to convey that okay next
one is describe a time when you had to
learn something new in short period how
did you manage I mean this is just a
different version of a previous question
we discussed so once again if you have
to learn something in like very short
time what is going to be the shortest
way you can start learning about maybe
you reach out to different people and
just just start learning the Rel
relevant information in instead of going
through the whole thing try to fix it
first and then go deeper into learning
the whole thing um as it on its own so
this can be one of the approaches okay
now let's move on to the next topic that
is the topic of adaptability how do you
ensure that you are adaptable once again
we are continuing on the same topic now
next one is tell me about a time when
you had to adapt your communication
style to suit a particular audience now
this goes back to the previous question
we discussed regarding regarding
presentation skills once again if you
are trying to solve a technical problem
but if you will have to explain it to a
business person you will have to use
different terminology you will have to
explain that what is going to be the
cost from the business standpoint cost
as in number of people working number of
time uh what are going to be the
resources you are going to using in like
maybe cloud or on premises in terms of
servers and networking components and
whatnot if you are speaking with some
technical or developer you are going to
be talking about how the packets are
going to be transferred what are the
database schema going to be how you are
going to store the data how you are
going to secure all the data what are
the gdpr compliance you are going to
follow what not if you are explaining
this to a scrum Master you will just
explain that hey these are the task we
need to do uh these should be the
timelines these should be the sequencing
of the task this is the purpose of each
one of them so depending on the person
team or stakeholder you are explaining
the situation to your Comm communication
needs to change because you cannot
explain the same thing to all different
people all so always that's why I have
some clear examples where you had to
deal with this type of situation and
then you would be golden next one is
describe an an instance where you had to
work with limited resources so limited
resources can be in terms of limited
time limited PE limited number of people
working on a project or limited set of
tools or technology available to you why
you were there what was your approach
how if let's say that there is only one
single license that you can use amongst
four different developers in the team so
how do you make sure that uh who is
going to work on what and because
everyone wants to use that license how
would you take care of it so maybe you
can have a license sharing situation
maybe you can create different time
slots and for one time slot person a is
going to work on for another time slot
person B is going to work on and you can
create these time time slots in
different different parts of so during
the other times people can focus on
their other duties or maybe they can be
like off work or take their like give
good rest to to themselves so this can
be a way for better resource allocation
resource sharing okay next one is can
you talk about a long-term project that
you manage how did you keep everything
moving along in a timely manner so I
think I just spoke about this like five
minutes back for this you need to ensure
that every frequent week weeks you are
keeping track of that uh what were your
expected timelines what are your current
timelines how close you are with the
expectation how uh further away you are
are you running in the red are you
running in the orange are you running in
the green are you ahead of schedule are
you behind the schedule are you way
behind the schedule if you are way
behind or behind the schedule how do you
adjust your timelines uh how do you
convey this message to the broader team
broader stakeholders why you started uh
falling behind in the timeline uh how do
you keep tracking of this maybe for like
next 2 years because some projects they
run like 2 to 4 years as well and in
some cases so how how do you keep all of
these things check for that you need
clear set of policies and processes in
place that you follow rigorously for the
entirety of that time with clear
discipline and uh always have all of the
entire audit trail of all the things
that happened and all the decisions were
made during that time okay next question
is tell me about about a time when you
had to B balance competing priorities
and how did you handle it so an example
for competing priorities could be maybe
you are working on Project a that is
coming to a deadline maybe the project
is not so significant like the product
is
relatively in low value or low impact
but that is coming closer to the
deadline meanwhile you are being asked
that this project B is really critical
but it is due in next 6 months and so
how do you manage that competing
priorities because on one hand you have
this product that is pretty close coming
to just end of its task but you still
want to make sure that you finish strong
and you complete all all the
responsibilities on the other side you
have this new project that is really
important in terms of priority but you
still have some time in between so maybe
you can put some more more effort
initially to complete this project and
get rid of it from your schedule and
then put more Focus towards b or maybe
you can start allocating like 30 or 30%
70% uh wait towards both the projects
you discuss this with your manager or
your product owner that what is the
importance of each one of them and uh
that will that way it would give you
clear indication on how much time you
want to allocate that is going to yield
the most impact for yourself for your
company and for your for your projects
so that that is the important part okay
next one is describe a situation where
you had to be patient in order to
achieve your goal again long running
projects you had to be very patient uh
next maybe you you might have to be
patient for uh that uh next technical
thing you are planning to do maybe you
were supposed to do last year but then
things change priorities change now you
are expect expecting to do it this year
but still you realize that you couldn't
make it how do you keep yourself
motivated how do you keep your team
motivated do you have that ability of
patience do you can you set up the clear
timeline lines and clear road maps for
the moving the path moving forward so
these these sort of things okay now
let's move on to the next topic that is
communication and let's go to the
question number 31 describe a situation
where you had to use your communication
skills to resolve a conflict again
pretty simple pretty easy maybe you
realize that there is some ongoing
conflict between two peoples or two
teams maybe to uh like yourself and your
manager and whatnot how do you resolve
that just simple thing
bring everything together ask
investigate what is the problem and then
come up with the solution explain to
each one of them that why they are in
that this situation how can they get out
of it what should be the approach moving
forward and uh what what would be like a
common solution that everyone can come
up with in with consensus so you can
think of your emotional intelligence and
your communication skills to come up
with the solution that tell me about a
time when you had to give critical
feedback to someone how did you approach
it now there is a very common saying
praise in public and criticize in
private follow the same rule if you
realize that maybe some of the employee
or someone some regarding some of their
behavior or their skills they are
lacking something and you feel like your
feedback would make an improvement feel
free to go ahead it's always a good
practice to give proper accurate
critical feedback to anyone and everyone
uh and also give it in a manner that
they take it well
show them that exactly what what what is
your intention why did you want it to do
that how did you how would you approach
it you approach it calmly gently uh you
give them specific examples and you also
give them that how can they improve on
the current situation plus confirm with
them that they don't feel discouraged
because you mention these things and you
are just trying to help them out you are
trying to do what's best for the company
and what's best for their own person
personal growth so that can be your
approach you can explain this type of
all the considerations in your interview
and it it's going to look really nice
okay next one is describe a project
where you took a creative approach to
solve a problem I think I we already
took care of very similar problems in
the past so I'm just going to skip ahead
with this question but make sure that
you explain the situation where and how
you become creative and uh talk about
all the different aspects of the
problems and situations and your uh in
genuine solution okay next one is can
you provide me an example of a time when
you had to juggle several projects at a
time this is pretty common because at
any given moment you might be working
somewhere between like 3 to 15 projects
depending on like how complex your work
schedule are and how stretched up
resources are so always uh set clear
priorities and the priorities defined by
the impact by the type of Headlines by
the work that needs to be done the skill
level the current project status and all
of these things so there is no one
particular reason about this there is a
huge topic about how do I manage
expectations and how do I manage
priorities in my opinion it is more of
an art than a rigorous set of rules you
always have to juggle about these
different things and think about oh hey
this needs to be done let me quickly fix
that this is important let me work upon
this this is important let me work upon
this on top of it at the same time you
will also have to realize that you only
have limited time at your hand so you
don't put too much on your plate if you
realize that there are some low priority
items just be confrontational or be
open-minded about it and just let the
the team know that this can be done
later or this can be done by someone
else feel free to delegate your work
delegation is a great way to manage
multiple items without losing the
efficiency so always do proper
delegation uh manage priorities and
explain that what are your effective
strategies to manage priorities
basically next question is how do you
prioritize your work when you have
multiple projects to handle I think it's
pretty much the same question so I'm
just going to go ahead okay next one is
describe a time when you had to use your
negotiation skills so you have to
negotiate on many different aspects at
your job you have to many times you have
to negotiate with the clients with the
consumers with your vendors with the
existing team members about the work you
needs to be done maybe with other team
members because you wants to convince
them that your project that you are
suggesting or the work you're trying to
do has more priorities and you are
willing to complete it with these many
resources under this time frame so what
is your negotiation approach always come
to a common ground understand that what
are all the different options available
and try to find the best path possible
for each one of them have some and
before you start negotiating always
understand that what is going to be the
end result because many times you are
negotiating with let's let's assume that
you are working at a company and you are
negotiating from someone else from a
different company you are trying to sell
your product to that company you do all
of these negotiations and you go through
the whole process for 3 months after 3
months you realize that now that person
also has to ask someone else to make
that decision which means maybe the
whole negotiation proc process can
restart again and you just wasted a lot
of time so always come to that
conclusion that what are going to be the
criterias that would be agreeable by
both who are going to be the
stakeholders making these decisions and
what are the different negotiating
approaches you would take always try to
use the Nash equilibrium concept that is
do what's best for both and uh you will
always find a common ground over there
okay next one is tell me about a time
when you had to manage conflicting
priorities yeah we just spoke about it
moving on to the next question that is
how do you handle constructive criticism
really important topic they really wants
to know that um are you a person who can
take feedback basically that's it if
you're doing something wrong and if
someone else tells you that you are
doing it wrong do you become more
defensive or do you become more
attentive towards what they are listen
what they are saying and then rather
than discrediting them or saying that no
no no this is not why I did that just be
open-minded maybe I made a mistake
everyone makes a mistake thank you so
much for Point pointing it out I'll try
to find a solution but if you already
know that what can be a better approach
also let me know I can think about it
understand or gain that expertise uh and
then take it with me so that next time I
don't make the same mistake that's a
great attitude if some if you can find a
person who can take the constructive
criticism in a better manner and work on
that improve on that and make sure to
not to repeat the same mistake twice
that person would end up becoming like
probably the most successful employee or
even the CEO of your company because
that is the correct right right mindset
you want everyone makes the mistake the
question is how many unique mistakes you
can make and the more unique mistakes
you make the smarter you are going to
become and I'm focusing the my emphasis
on the word unique because you don't
want to make the same mistake quick
again and again that's just the
definition of insanity okay so now
moving on to the next question can you
describe a time when you had to
communicate complex information
clearly maybe there are some exact
requirements that needs to be met maybe
you need to convey the message to
different teams and you want to ensure
that the Integrity of information
remains constant they all understand so
how do you do that one approach is you
explain what you are showing you note it
down write it down have a share point
share it with everyone plus you reach
out to them and confirm that did they
understand what you are trying to convey
gather that information make sure that
you both are on the same page so you
don't miss out the important details in
the somewhere between communication and
then there is some misunderstanding and
in the end you you are expecting to have
almonds and you get peaches so don't
don't be like that okay
next one is describe a situation where
you had to actively listen to someone
and understand their perspective this
can be once again go back to my very
previous examples I gave where about an
employee not pulling their weight just
because I was trying to understand their
situation I was putting more emphasis on
listening what they had to say
understanding what they had to suffer
and it wasn't like initially that
employee was reluctant to give me the
whole story on why that employee is not
able to do and why he's not meeting the
deadlines but somewhere along the lines
I understood that maybe there might be
some other issues apart from the work
related thing that might be hampering
that that decision and the work uh
efficiency and that was the case so
active listening is lot of parts it is
trying to understand person's scenario
it involves lot of emotional
intelligence
and read lot of reading between the
lines plus you need to be attentive that
you are understanding what each and
everything that other person is
conveying to you without any like biases
or judgments or whatnot so make sure to
give an example that elaborate this kind
of scenario that would really look good
for your behavioral interviews okay now
the last topic that is leadership now
this topic is mostly going to be for
folks who are applying for like more
senior level positions maybe like
managerial or director level or VP level
position and I'm pretty sure that they
must have done hundreds of interviews
throughout their career so they might
have most of the idea um I don't have
much leadership experience but if I have
to give an example or if I am taking an
interview these are the things I would
be expecting so this is what I would
explain for each one of the questions
and uh again make sure to make your own
answers make your own reflect your own
self and see where uh the answer suits
you okay give me an example of a goal
you set and how did you achieve it so
goal can be for your personal self or
maybe for your team or for your company
for your project maybe it can be a
short-term goal long-term goal how did
you keep track of it uh how did you
ensure that you are moving in the
correct direction if you face any
setbacks how did you get out from that
so these are all the things you can talk
about it if I have to talk about it I
can talk about my YouTube channel
because initially like that was not my
goal but after making like somewhere
around 50 60 videos it became my goal
that I want to initially start talking
about like all the data structure and
algorithm related questions then I
started talking about system Design
Concepts then I started talking about
behavioral interviews then I then I'll
start talking about maybe different
languages so my goal post is to create
like this broader ecosystem of challenge
channel that contains lot of information
that is going to be helpful for all the
folks uh in their career so that that's
my goal uh now next question is have you
ever had to make an unpopular decision
how did you handle the feedback
unpopular decision can be anything maybe
there is a service or a perk you are
cutting out maybe you you have to lay
off some people uh maybe you have to
change some things in a company that is
going to impose some stricter policies
that might create an additional workload
or headache for different people but it
can be helpful in the long run so how
did you handle the feedback first you
make sure to convey your message that
why you are taking the step and then
realize that what are the concerns
different teams are coming back up with
have that open mindness have that uh
like active listening component to it
realize that what is the feedback maybe
there might be some things that you
might have missed so if you if that is
the case how did you handle it can you
try to go ahead and fix it are you able
to take take yourself accountable that
hey this is the thing I supposed to do
but I forgot about these three different
dimensions or options and uh let me fix
that I'm accountable for that I'm
responsible for that and I'm making that
change so it always shows you as a as a
better human being okay next one is have
you ever exper have you ever worked on a
project that failed how did you learn
from that experience like almost
everyone has worked on some project that
failed maybe it failed because of lack
of resources or the product didn't do
well or the product you build was not
very viable maybe some other competitor
came up with a better product that it
eventually died or maybe you never
finished the project maybe the
priorities change maybe the resources
working on were not not there and it
went way over budget or way out of
bounds like the failed projects are the
best test case scenario that helps you
grow significantly because then you
would know that these are the 10 Things
I should not be doing think of Thomas
Alva Edison Edison failed to make the
light bu first 1,000 times still kept on
trying with better material different
methods eventually we are all living in
the world of electricity so that's
that's the approach okay next one is can
you give me an example of how you
handled High tress high stress situation
I think I spoke about this earlier but
still like working under pressure and
going above and beyond for your job so
this is very similar to that but when
you are speaking about like leadership
level high stress stress can be with
like Bad Company results maybe um having
a product not do its job or you have you
might have to lay off some people or you
realize that your entire portfolio is
going to change how would you deal with
that so you always try to keep yourself
calm uh think about all the different
options different parameters if you can
seek advice reach out to different
people take feedback uh think out loud
always writing always helps whenever you
are in a precarious situation so these
can be different coping mechanisms you
can take take on hand next one is tell
me about a time when you had to take
responsibility for an error made by
someone else I can give you a very good
example uh this was like Dr apj Abdul
Kalam now for those who don't know he's
uh he he is an Indian Prime president
and he was also a scientist who was
working on lot of like satellite
launches for India for Indian space
research organization
so he once gave an example where he was
like uh he was working on a project and
they tried to launch the satellite but
it failed midair and then it crashed and
um that time it was a huge setback for
the
company now at that time he mentioned
that he was the project manager he was
the he was responsible for that failure
but his director came out in public in
press and said everyone that the
director said that I failed I made a uh
judgment call maybe this was an error we
understand that this was the fault we
assess all the failures and now we are
going to work upon it to fix our
mistakes and then we will make sure that
we move forward with uh the
success Dr apj Abdul Kalam he became
like really uh like questioned that why
because he knew that he was responsible
and still that director had faith in him
he's like don't worry I have faith
everyone makes the mistake now we we we
will have to make sure that we deliver
it successfully and after 2 years they
launched the same satellite with success
and that paved a path for which like all
the achievements that Indian space
research agency made um in their space
program so you can understand that how a
leadership position person being
accountable for
himself while motivating his or her team
is actually making significant impact
for the accountability and also
shielding the inner team from lot of
that outside of uh bounds or outside of
uh like negativity that could be coming
out so always if you have such
experiences feel free to share it and
explain that why did you do that and
what was the outcome of it okay next
question is that how do you assess
success of a project Give an example
like couple of common example on time
and on budget these are the two major
factors next one is once the project has
been deployed or is running in the
production or consumers are using what
is the response how they are taking it
how they are treating it how what people
has to say about it for that you have to
take constant feedbacks plus you can
also learn that can your project become
a framework for other projects that you
are going to do in the future then it
makes makes it a legendary project so
these are all the different parameters
and you can also explain for each
project that you worked upon you can
give like two three examples that this
project I worked upon I feel like
success was uh building and delivering a
critical uh application in like shorter
time frame using the completely new text
text T with like five different teams
working in tandem to get it done so this
can be also one of the examples okay
next is tell me about a time when you
had to dis out without all the
information you needed so maybe you are
in some high stress situation situ high
stress scenario and you have to make a
decision because if you wait to gather
all the information it might be too late
or you might be losing too much money so
there is a a fine line you will have to
cross
between like efficiency and Defiance
that you don't want to Define you don't
want to be that dict dictatorial person
that hey just because I said so do it
but you also want to make sure that you
are taking the calculated risk that if
you take this option or this option
without having all the background or all
the key information what are going to be
their different approaches and if you
have ever have to face that situation uh
then yeah feel free to explain that next
one is describe a situation where you
had to analyze the data and make a
recommendation what approach did you
take there was there there have been
very famous movies on analyzing data and
then making some decisions Like Money
Ball and big short if you haven't
watched them go ahead and watch them but
in your case if you have to make some
decisions based on the data first
realize that what type of data you are
dealing with and what type of decision
you are making maybe you are trying to
make a decision that in your existing
company you are currently operating in
three different regions now you wants to
operate in two more regions and you have
these seven regions to pick from what
are going to be the criteria you would
be looking for so in that case data
would be what is the property rates what
are the uh con what what type of sensus
is there how many number of people are
living what are their nationalities
ethnicities uh culture groups what what
are the products you are trying to Shipe
or deploy what is going to be the
logistics what are going to be the cost
of each one of them what are the
prospects of earning money so these are
the data that you should be looking at
and the based on that you would be able
to make decisions plus right now you can
also use lot of like data science and
machine learning and AI to make
decisions using the data because data is
a huge commodity and that can give you
great great Insight on the future
predictor of things that you are trying
to do so that's why Always uh take take
data very seriously next question is
have you ever faced an ethical dilemma
at work how did you handle it like I
personally have never faced an ethical
dilemma but I can give you an example
like maybe say for an example you
realize that one of your
employee um who works under you and that
employee did something unintentional you
know for sure that that employee did
something
unintentional and they realize that that
was their mistake now the question is if
you go out and say the same thing to the
HR you that employee is for sure getting
fired now if you don't say it to the HR
you are not doing your job as a manager
the other thing is that the
unintentional wrong thing that employe
did maybe it was yeah it was wrong but
the impact was not like no no one got
hurt nobody got impacted but it was a
wrong thing to do so this is the ethical
dilemma how do you approach it so first
you assess all the situations like if I
personally have to do
it I might give like a slap on the wrist
for that employee if they
unintentionally did it and they realize
that mistake if they intentionally did
it for sure I'm going to complain to the
HR but uh if it is unintentional and
maybe hey mistakes anyone can make and
they didn't know and it caused no harm
but I will give like a return email
showing that hey these are the things
you did they should not have been done
and like warning like maybe strike one
and strike two at the same time but I
would make sure I would try at least
that that person does not lose his or
her job and then maybe ruin their entire
career so this would be one of the
ethical dilemas that I I I can think of
okay next one is describe a situation
where you had to took a risk and paid
off once again taking calculated risk
understanding all the information maybe
you have all the relevant data maybe you
don't have all the relevant data if you
have the data how would it impact your
judgment if you don't have the data how
would it impact impact your judgment so
think of these things and this concludes
all the 50 answers now once again for
all the 50 answers I hope you were
following along and I'm sorry if I kept
on and on about different questions but
make sure that the for these questions
you have your own set of answers now
let's move on to the next topic and that
is dealing with difficult questions so
once again all no questions are made uh
equal some questions might be easy some
questions might be difficult some
questions might be easy for some people
some question might be easy for
difficult people so it depends varies
from people to people but always make
sure that you understand that why the
question is difficult and that's where
it came along that uh Hey if you are
giving the question that give me an
example where you had to persuade the
others the important Crux of this
question is why did you had to persuade
the others what was the exact scenario
and then what was your approach on
persuing others for what you are trying
to propose so this this can be one of
the examples uh next thing is whenever
you have to speak about or talk about
different weaknesses and failures of
yourself be open to that many times I've
seen like and I I personally experienced
that in the past as well that I was was
always too reluctant to talk about my
failures and uh the mistakes I made or
weaknesses I had but as I grew more
mature in my career I realized that this
is what made me what I am today all the
mistakes I did all the weaknesses I had
and I had to overcome that that gave me
a huge confidence boost it gave me the
sincerity of how wrong things can happen
how can I learn from that how can I move
away from that why why should not not I
not carry it on my shoulder as a burden
but rather than use it as a fourth step
to climb that next step and learn that
uh next next thing so always understand
that these are some of the strategies
you can have on your self whenever you
are dealing with a difficult question
first try to stay calm and compose you
can ask the uh interviewer that hey can
I take like a 30 second pause or a 1
minute pause um just to think about the
formulate how to formulate the answer
what are all the aspects I'm going to
talk about it maybe make some bullet
points in your head and then start
formalizing the answer using the star
methodology okay so this can be one of
the good approaches always try to stay
calm if you even if you encounter some
questions that are like way out of your
imagination at least stay calm like uh
previously Google used to ask this funny
question that why manhole CS are circle
and not Square in the New York City
makes no sense but still they are ask
they ask many people the same questions
what you going to do if you don't know
the answer well some people be like if I
want to go down straight I don't want to
get myself hurt across 90° angles so it
was yeah that that was a pretty good
answer actually so there can be many
examples okay now let's understand that
how can you incorporate emotional
intelligence in your interview and in
your answers emotional intelligence is
something that comes with practice and
seeing things the way they are and the
way they are not it's like trying to
understand both sides of the coin and
how it can come into your answers or
your interview you always wants to be
empathized and try to find the root of
the cost so again even if the
interviewer is asking you a question try
to understand that what is the root
behind this question what is the purpose
they are looking for or if you're giving
some
answer did you thought about all the
scenarios were you dealing with empathy
so these are the things you want to
always make sure that you want to be
demonstrating that you are a person who
has lot of empathy for different people
and that makes the situation 10 times
lighter plus if you are self-aware about
your behavior and what human Tendencies
other people can do then it helps you
make more sense of the situation and try
to tread the waters carefully okay and
uh of course make sure that you balance
the professional and personal lives and
scenarios you don't mix them it's never
a good idea so always do that so
emotional intelligence in action is um
if you want there are actually lot of
movies that have emotional intelligence
in action but think about Michael Katon
from The Dark Knight Rises uh or sorry
the the original Dark Knight where he's
explaining to Bruce Banner or Bruce
Wayne that um
why Joker was doing all of these things
and then he explained the the things
about that some men just want to watch
the world burn so you can't reason with
them you can't argue with them but you
just have to deal with him and that gave
Batman an idea that how to deal with the
choker so this can be that that shows
that the butler Michael Katon in that
movie is a person with extreme emotional
intelligence and sees the world from
different angle now this is nowhere near
in terms of correlation with your actual
interview
but it's just an
example okay next topic is non-verbal
communication how do you behave and how
do you speak without speaking this is
really important your body posture and
gestures they make significant
difference so how do you take care of it
your body language you need to set up in
like a good manner sit try to sit
straight try to look them in the eye try
to smile here and there Everyone likes a
smiling face and uh try to use like your
hand gestures your body gestures in in a
decent manner use the space around that
is currently available in the room now
with the interviews there are now always
going to be two scenarios either you are
giving on premise interview or onsite
interview or you are giving a virtual
interview in both scenarios the
consideration for non-verbal
communication would be completely
different if you are in person in place
how do you ensure that your non-verbal
communication is on point smile here and
there have a good EYC cont
make sure that you are sitting at a
reasonably well distance even if a
conference room has a huge table you
don't want to sit too close with each
other you don't want to sit too away
from each other uh just like use the
space around yourself but don't use it
too crazily or too aggressively and just
be overall in the moment so that that is
going to feel really good Plus have like
smiling facial expression don't have
creepy Smiles or something like that but
just like everyone loves us a smiling
face next thing is uh if you have to
talk about the virtual interviews few
topics would be at least try to look
directly in the camera uh try to make
sure that your background is clear or
you are using appropriate filters uh
your mic is working you are reasonably
well-dressed your hair looks good your
face looks good you are uh at least
being presentable for that that
interview and you are giving it the
sincerity that interview deserves so
always be mindful of that and now let's
talk about some of the important
preparation strategies I know we have
been talking quite a lot about all the
different preparation strategies we can
have throughout this entire session but
now let's just talk about few of them
number one make sure to write all the
stories and all the experience
experiences you had ideally for each of
the five categories we we talk about
maybe have like three stories for each
one of them if you have like somewhere
around 15 to 20 stories you are set you
would be able to give all all of the
different options and uh any type of
questions can be asked you now you just
have to pinpoint okay for the in order
to explain the disagreement with myself
with a colleague this is the story I'm
going to say in order for a disagreement
with from myself with a client this is
what I'm going to explain what not and
all always make sure that you are
practicing everything with star
methodology situation t ask action
result all four four things because that
way you are following up the whole
timeline of the question you are taking
the interviewer throughout the exact
situation and also ending up at what was
the result achieved in the end so
practice the star method for each of the
stories that you are going to write at
least write one or two points that is
going to be just for yourself so you can
quickly remind yourself that hey this
was the situation and this was the
action we took and this was what we did
okay next thing is if you can do mock
interviews this is going to be really
important find your friends find some
group maybe there are some online
communities reach out to them find some
strangers you take their Mock and you
give mock interviews to them this is
going to be a win-win for both of you
you would be able to see from the
perspective of an interviewer whenever
someone else is giving the answer that
how does it feel and what was your
intent and did they justify your intent
or not and the more interviews you give
the better and sharper your answers will
get so always I cannot emphasize enough
if you just do mock interviews you would
be set and just any curveball any random
questions can be thrown at you be in the
moment this is a great opportunity for
you to outshine yourself to show the
interviewer that what type of person you
are what type of character you have what
are the experience es you have learned
so behavioral interview in my opinion is
a great way to Showcase your skill and
that's why take it as an opportunity
rather than an obstacle and uh it's
going to be really helpful now we are
going to talk about few resources so
number one just take these two books
they are really popular books cracking
the coding interview or 101 great
answers to the toughest interview
questions like there are online copies
available there are copies on the Amazon
available pick whatever you want to and
U if you are a reader just go through
them there are lot of online courses
available on LinkedIn learning corser
and Udi plus this course you already
have this so I did not mention YouTube
but since you are already watching this
on YouTube so of course you YouTube is
also going to be there there are some
popular subreddits on the reddit website
so if you want to go to like jobs or
interviews or CS career questions
specifically for Tech uh inter tech jobs
all the these three are really good
really popular they help you out with
the resume reviews and questions and
answers so you can understand what type
of questions are being asked what are
the expectations at different companies
they also help you with like negotiation
strategies and salaries and whatnot okay
next one couple of really good websites
levels. FYI because it shows lot of
different things on different companies
how they behave and what are the
benefits they have the pugs they have
the employees they have the compensation
they have and plus they have a a very
good Community page so that they have a
very active Community where you can post
many questions and next one is glass
door where the appropriate employees of
any particular company leave their
experiences and reviews for that company
so that can come in really
handy